[Music]
wheat barley rye breakfast time for the
chickens at an organic farm in kurtal in
northern Germany for 32 year old Shahi
Xiao from Tanzania feeding the chickens
is the first job of the day sometimes I
miss home yeah when I get to feed the
chickens here yeah it reminds me of
feeding the chickens also as well at
home so it's the same the same process
of feeding them but in another place and
so you get some memories of what you do
back at home back at home cahaya whose
family also runs a farm studied natural
resource management at university here
in germany he is volunteering for the
year he's not earning much money but
instead he's learning different farming
methods Tanzania we have our chickens
more mostly staying indoors by for us
and we give them just a food bought food
from the animal feeds that's prepared
food and they don't get the chance
really to go out and eat green green
stuff shahi stay has been organized by
german foundation and his host is
organic farmer and del colle a kitch
today he's teaching cahaya how to make
nutrient-rich soil rotten fruit and
vegetables from the farmer broken down
into compost and mixed with horse dung
this soil has been in preparation for
two years
Shahana is taking it to be sterilized to
kill off bacteria and weeds via your
unball Gardens organic farmers we want
to have sustainable agriculture we make
our own soil and try to create a closed
cycle therefore our own compost our own
earth and everything we produce here
goes back into the cycle building
but creating this eco-friendly cycle is
labor-intensive everything has to be
done by hand Anshe hires family farm in
Tanzania they use pesticides and
herbicides to kill off insects and weeds
chemicals are useful in controlling
diseases in the tropical climate but
they take a big toll on the soil and the
surrounding environment we is slowly
toll killing the the biodiversity and I
think that's not sustainable for a long
term because we need also the insects
for also in our environment as well and
they're better if we can control it in
another way rather than using the
poisonous substances time for lunch
besides an environmental focus the farm
also has a social aspect it provides a
home for disabled people
Jehiel works with them in the garden and
also helps them with day-to-day tasks I
had no experience before so I also had
to learn how to work with them in the
Guardian and yeah it's a challenging but
with time you learn how to to have
teamwork you need a lot of patience but
in the long run they are able to work
and deliver results and it helps them at
the farm shop it's a veritable organic
feast cooperation with other organic
farms means that people here have more
than enough to choose from it's
different for sure higher at home water
shortages and disease mean that not
everyone always has enough to eat shahi
has another six months left in Germany
when he gets back home he plans on
starting his own organic farm
I really look forward to having the same
model or bombing in Tanzania and see
whether it will work out about a pink
stripe weight sustainable it's
environmentally friendly living with
nature in producing food with the aim of
maybe more people will come on board and
also to produce enough for everyone
Shahana is sharing his experiences in
Germany he's writing about them in a
blog and if you'd like to know more
about his life as an eco volunteer check
it out DW comm forward slash eco blog